en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco Bueno
pues en el evento Internacional del que
todo el mundo habla la coronación del
Rey Carlos de Inglaterra y más allá del
evento en Sí vamos a hablar de los
desafíos y retos que se le presentan al
nuevo monarca para ello nos acompañan en
este estudio Alan Reading periodista
británico es corresponsal del New York
Times good mornings Reading
nos acompaña también él la tomasini
periodista independiente bienvenida Good
morning
y en dúples nos acompaña Arnaldo mera
historiador de la pontificia Universidad
Católica de Perú experto en casas reales
bienvenido Arnaldo Buenos días Buenos
días Me da mucho gusto estar otra vez
aquí con ustedes 24 así como cuando
estuvimos en el deceso de la Reina
Isabel II Ahora nos toca estar presentes
para conversar algo sobre el tema de la
futura coronación pues efectivamente se
abre la era de Carlos de Inglaterra hoy
nuestro asunto en Primera Plana
hacía 70 años que no se celebraba un
ritual de coronación en Reino Unido y
por muchas razones las comparativas
entre el Rey Carlos y su madre la Reina
Isabel II van a ser inevitables la
coronación de 1953 mostró a una monarca
joven que llegó al Trono tras la muerte
de su padre el rey Jorge sexto y se
convirtió en un icono muy querido muchos
dicen que la corona sobrevivió Gracias a
ella a diferencia a sus 74 años Carlos
llega al Trono ya siendo una figura muy
conocida cuyos defectos han sido
analizados en los medios de comunicación
durante décadas y que sigue siendo la
cabeza de una familia cuyas rencillas
últimamente han dejado a la casa de
Windsor muy dividida en momentos de
inflación y de asperezas económicas para
Londres parece que entre los británicos
ha bajado la ilusión por celebrar la
realeza ahora les pregunto a mis
invitados antes repasemos la prensa
portadas como ésta del ifning estándar
han mostrado los preparativos para la
coronación en Londres y todo el
dispositivo de seguridad la implicación
política del nuevo rey ha aparecido en
esta portada de I news el plan de Reino
Unido para Carlos tercero para
reconducir las relaciones con Europa
tras el brexit precisamente aquí en
Francia Carlos III ha sido portada en
París dice la publicación en su
principal Tribuna que los Windsor aman
Francia bueno Alan esta coronación no sé
si cumple a la perfección aquella dicha
Popular de que las comparaciones son
odiosas lo digo por madre e hijo Bueno
estamos aquí para hacer la comparación
Exacto Exacto si no no me voy
efectivamente pero la sombra de Isabel
II va a ser demasiada alargada
No ella se había vuelto una especie de
símbolos también sombra no no era activa
como antes no viajaba mucho por el mundo
Bueno ya ya no viajaba entonces pero sí
era un símbolo y como la la las familias
reales son sobre todo símbolos en en
países democráticos este desaparece el
símbolo y aparece una persona con quien
tenemos que tratar ahora ella con cuando
se se cuando se coronó tenían 256 años
entonces no era no tenían grandes
formación políticas ideas y todo eso era
un poco inesperado su padre murió así
Carlos ha tenido muchos años tiene 74
años y tiene 50 años de de opinando y
teniendo opiniones que y él tenía el
derecho a hacerlo Aunque muchas veces
producía
resistencia quejas y todo pero ya se
sabe que hay algunos temas que le
interesa ahora él ha prometido que no va
a opinar pero como es un símbolo como
como tú dices por ejemplo el hecho de
brexit relación con Europa es el mero
hecho de viajar ya iba a venir a Francia
primero pero un ciertos disturbios aquí
entonces se fue a Alemania pero es un
símbolos no es que dice vamos a a
intercambiar comercio entonces vendrá a
Francia pronto y entonces este tipo de
idea de que para él le importa la cosa
importante es mantener esta red Entonces
eso sí como símbolo ahora
Inglaterra es el problema para él o Gran
Bretaña Porque tanto ha cambiado y ahora
las presiones sobre la la familia real
para que para ser más abierto es decir
cuestión de familia Ya hemos hablado
desde todo de los problemas eternos de
de la familia en las peleas y todos los
cuestión de dinero este Cuánto ganan
cuánto tienen porque tienen tanto cuánto
impuesto pagan estas preguntas nunca se
hacían con la reina y ahora se van a
fiscalizar más digamos pero la presión y
después la historia es decir antes no se
hablaba de cómo lo los ingleses o los
muchos otros países se hicieron ricos y
ahora se habla de esclavitud y eso
cuestiona en relación a las excolonias
que dicen espérate Nosotros somos
colonizados muchos retos encima de la
mesa para el nuevo monarca Elda Sí yo
creo que ese es el mayor desafío que
tiene Carlos justamente las tendencias
independentistas que existen en el Reino
Unido Cómo va a trabajar él cola como un
Wells que ha cambiado mucho y ahí sí un
poco la sombra de la reina que fue como
era joven pero hizo un gran gran trabajo
y Bueno ahora se espera que él haga algo
parecido Obviamente el contexto como
dice de una gran inflación que hay en
hoy en el Reino Unido y un montón de
otras circunstancias sin ir más lejos
cómo va a ser la transmisión fue
histórica la transmisión de la
coronación de la reina la primera vez en
la televisión Y tuvo un montón de cosas
que hoy es un contexto totalmente
diferente así que todo eso influye
muchísimo vamos a hablar aquí de los
Perdón Alan tú dices la primera es bueno
había una televisión y no había eso hoy
hay cincuenta mil televisiones todo el
mundo opinando todo el mundo cree que es
importante y todo el mundo va a estar
opinando claro estamos hablando aquí de
los retos a futuro del nuevo monarca
pero vamos a hablar también del pasado
con nuestro historiador con Arnaldo mera
desde la Universidad Católica del Perú
experto en casas reales Arnaldo En qué
se distingue esta coronación de las
anteriores las coronaciones se han ido
repitiendo de igual manera tal vez desde
el siglo noveno hasta la coronación de
la reina Victoria pero
cambiando los títulos de Rey de
Inglaterra a rey del Reino Unido de Gran
Bretaña Irlanda luego al rey de Unido de
Capitán se le unió el emperador de la
India rey de Australia del Rey Nueva
Zelanda pero lo más importante es que el
evento siempre había sido un evento para
los británicos de los británicos para
sus colonias Y eso va a cambiar
totalmente
eso va a cambiar totalmente ahora
Estamos viendo una coronación por
meritocracia ya no gasta presente la
aristocracia completa de los ocho mil
invitados Isabel segunda ochocientos
eran los títulos mobiliarios ahora no se
han considerado ni a Los Duques todo un
cambio completo de estrategia del reino
de Gran Bretaña Irlanda del Norte
actualmente cambian los tiempos Alan y
es lo que vamos a ver en la coronación y
con la coronación interesante en para la
Reina Isabel Elizabeth era totalmente
cristiano pero más a eso anglicano ahora
Carlos que siempre ha tenido religioso
Sí pero pero Carlos que siempre ha
tenido una visión mucho más amplia mucho
más ecuménica entonces se ha asegurado
que están invitados los representantes
del islam
de judíos los
todo el mundo está presente no no No
necesariamente estarán obligados curar
su su lealtad al rey porque como le
están pidiendo al a todo el Inglaterra
sí a mí eso me parece que como un cambio
de los más interesantes porque ella no
se presenta solamente como el defensor
de una religión sino como Bueno vamos a
respetar todos los credos y todos los
cultos y todas las religiones Eso me
parece que habla muchísimo de la
apertura que tiene Carlos que como bien
decía él actúa más Más allá de lo que
opine tiene los gestos y sus acciones
como símbolo es mucho más importante que
hay alguna declaración en favor de eso
el 64% de los británicos dice tener poco
o nulo interés según el sondeo de yugov
y entre los jóvenes Se dispara me
refiero el interés de los británicos por
la coronación este desinterés Alan es
un acontecimiento en un acontecimiento
tan mediático se lo atribuimos más al
protagonista en sí a Carlos o al momento
que vive Reino Unido de crisis de
inflación de subida de los precios o hay
un componente intergeneracional
hay un poco de todo evidentemente hay
tanta competencia de información y
atención en relación si fuera la la el
matrimonio de Carlos con Dayana por
ejemplo Eso sí tuvo un aspecto romántico
Aunque inventado romántico no es decir
sí por casualidad Carlos muera pronto
este la coronación de William será más
mediático pero todo uno conoce Carlos y
ya demasiado en el sentido ya se estamos
acostumbrado a a a lo que es y como es y
más Los pequeños escándalos pero como
decimos Gran Bretaña ha cambiado Esa es
la cuestión de la devolución de poderes
hacia los los elementos a Escocia a
Irlanda del Norte
No yo personalmente No veo inminente la
independencia de Escocia y no creo que
él pueda hacer mucho pero también
simbólicamente visitando tienen sus sus
sus sus sus sus mansiones en en Escocia
andan muchas veces con su con su
vestidito Entonces le voy a preguntar a
Arnaldo mera porque hablábamos Antes de
que los tiempos cambian qué supone este
evento para Reino Unido un evento
histórico que pagan los contribuyentes
pero que la corona a su vez reporta
mucho a las arcas del Estado un dato la
coronación de 1953 fue un negocio
enormemente costoso y la coronación de
sals no será tan lujosa no se entendería
un derroche de lujos ahora en este
contexto de inflación y con tensiones
sociales Arnaldo la mentalidad británica
la mentalidad británica
que tenía en la expectativa de los
súbditos británicos de 1953 es
totalmente diferente a una mentalidad
actual del siglo XXI porque se acababa
de ganar la Segunda Guerra Mundial el
país estaba en crisis habían sido
bombardeados casi hasta semididas
algunas ciudades Incluyendo a Londres
los niños de diez años estaban
presenciando esa Corona lo que Winston
Churchill como Primer Ministro hizo y lo
que quiso hacer porque la reina en
realidad intervino poco porque la reina
reina Pero no gobierna entonces hay que
dejar claro eso fue ensalzar el orgullo
británico una coronación que magnificara
como si se volvieran a los tiempos de la
reina Victoria tiempos yaídos tiempos ya
perdidos eso es historia ahora estamos
con un momento de una crisis económica
galopante el brexit y los ha golpeado la
gente se cuestiona la institución tal
vez por eso se redujo a un nivel mínimo
la la existencia de invitado el número
de invitados se redujo los números de
aristócratas los números de
personalidades Entonces estamos ante una
una coronación que gusta uno y no gusta
a otros los tiempos cambian a menudo se
presenta Carlos III como un rey de
transición entre su madre y su nieto
Guillermo claro la
la mayor complejidad es dotar de entidad
propia su reinado porque va a ser más
corto eso ya lo sabemos Y eso de momento
en su gran desafío dotar de identidad a
un reinado que será más corto y que
muchos ven como de transición Sí pero de
todas maneras yo creo que él ha
construido una imagen que los británicos
conocen bien y obviamente ya tienen una
opinión formada lo que yo creo que
justamente es el cambio de los tiempos
que hacen que no quieran tanto a la
monarquía en general Más allá de lo que
más allá de su figura Me parece que el
rol que puede ocupar va a depender mucho
de cómo se desarrolle la economía de
cómo intervenga y del rol que tenga como
para seguir manteniendo unida aunque no
hay riesgos vienen varios referendos
cómo va a ser exactamente y también Cómo
va ese cómo se va a desempeñar como jefe
de estado en la como un Wells porque
tenemos que tener en cuenta eso que no
es solamente de un solo lugar vamos a
irnos a una pausa la vuelta hablamos de
la común well de su faceta ecologista
y de la reina consorte de Camila que
bueno está ahí ya que sacar el tema
volvemos enseguida especial
viva la coronación en directo desde
Londres mañana Carlos tercero prestará
el tradicional juramento en la abadía de
una ceremonia histórica para la corona
británica seguida del desfile hasta Los
Balcones del Palacio de bookingham y
durante todo el fin de semana en Londres
y Windsor únase al ambiente de la
celebraciones en nuestras ediciones
especiales Carlos tercero tras los pasos
de sus predecesores un momento de la
historia británica únase a este evento
con nuestra programación especial en
France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en France 24 y Franz 24.com
en France 24 punto com siga nuestra
transmisión en vivo
encuentre toda la información que
necesita
noticias en directo las 24 horas del día
y en cuatro idiomas
infórmese sobre los temas que le
interesan
Busca la actualidad o la repetición de
una emisión conéctese
a un clic la información internacional
en directo
libertad
Seguimos aquí esta semana en Primera
Plana analizando los retos que le
esperan al nuevo rey de Inglaterra
Carlos III lo hacemos con los
periodistas Alan riding él la tomasini y
Arnaldo mera Ávalos Y historiador
por cierto Alan ridín llegó a conocer a
Carlos III no efectivamente pero era
príncipe Entonces yo no no he conocido
el no fue un matrimonio donde el El
padrino del del novio yo era el padrino
de la novia Entonces nos juntamos ahí y
Cómo fue ese encuentro con con el nuevo
rey no Y además este muy generosamente
el el prestó uno de sus palacios para la
recepción después del matrimonio Así que
no sentimos bastante cerca de la
aristocracia pero un punto interesante
en términos de la relación con la
aristocracia en Inglaterra
este gobierno Ya llevan cinco primer
ministros conservadores hay un
desencanto tan profundo y hay una
relación en la cabeza de los ingleses de
los conservadores y No necesariamente la
familia real pero la aristocracia la el
poder rural las entonces hay hay un
ánimo hay huelgas hay hay un desánimo en
Inglaterra como dijiste ahí inflación
este en general nadie está en en en
Manchester City gana el Champions League
Tal vez van a sentir mejor pero pero por
este en general los ingleses los
británicos se siente mal hay peleas en
en Escocia entre ellos en Irlanda del
Norte entre ellos Entonces nadie está en
gran humor para hacer una fiesta
entonces Bueno ahí viene tiene que
hacerlo y cuando conoció a al Rey Carlos
qué impresión le dio en el en el
contacto de teta cercano en el contacto
humano muy directo muy directo primero
este mi compadre me presentó como
periodista en lo que obviamente se ve y
bonitos ojos que no le gustaba mucho la
idea de periodista y acá es un
periodista aquí pero después
Eternamente un dolor de cabeza para toda
la familia y para implantar buenas New
York Times
Ah y ahí entonces comentó Ah no
diferente la prensa aquí es espantosa
bueno Cómo sabemos No solo él pero sus
hijos pensar y ahora y en general la
Diana etcétera toda la historia es muy
Trágica con la prensa inglesa pero los
Mira la gente hace la prensa pop
Inglaterra tabloide Busca vender
periódicos punto Entonces si pueden
inventar un escándalo pagar a una
persona a mentir lo que sea lo hacen es
esa vergüenza ser periodista por eso que
no soy periodista
sin duda sacudida y también empañada por
los acontecimientos de los últimos cinco
años todos los tabloides que han sacado
familiares Cómo va a gestionar el Rey
Carlos todos las rencillas familiares
Que
helio entre hermanos la verdad No sabría
decirte porque Bueno vamos a ver qué
pasa la no la tiene no la tiene para
nada fácil me parece Me parece que lo
que más difícil como yo insisto que más
allá de de eso creo que hay algo que es
bueno que le pasa a Carlos que lo
conversamos un poco que es también todo
lo que se conoce ahora de él más allá de
toda su vida por ejemplo la serie de
Crown y todo como que también fuera de
lo que es Inglaterra que conocen bien la
historia para el resto de las personas
que que no estábamos tan familiarizadas
una serie Así ha puesto como muy en
primer foco su historia sobre todo con
Camila que que no era tan conocida no y
poniéndole un paño me parece como más
romántico y más de amor a todo lo que es
esa esa relación no porque también hay
muchos medios que dicen bueno sacan
otras historias de la familia para que
no se hable tanto solamente de ese
vínculo pero yo creo que bueno se ha
mostrado otra faceta no también de cómo
llegar a una pareja que empezó de una
forma muy
bueno prohibida y que fue un escándalo a
hoy consolidarse ella reina consorte y
mañana reina
cierta forma su relación con Camila Es
normal la relación con Diana no era
normal era una un matrimonio organizado
un poco como
otro siglo claro como ahora les voy a
preguntar por la por la nueva reina
consorte Camila pero antes le voy a
preguntar a nuestro historiador Arnaldo
mera precisamente por esta cuestión
tensiones entre hermanos cuñadas
contracciones mediáticas de por medio
esta especie de Juego de tronos en el
que se ha convertido la casa real
británica da mucho juego a la ficción a
los medios por supuesto pero hasta qué
punto deteriora la imagen de la corona o
Su futuro no depende tanto de ello
cuando la reina Victoria quedó viuda se
encerró en el Palacio de buckingham y no
salía o en el castillo de Wilson y no se
dejaba ver por nadie en un momento dado
quedan los testimonios de las
discusiones y debates en el parlamento
de hechicería mejor o mejor
o conveniente establecer una República y
estamos hablando del reinado de la reina
más querido hoy en día y más recordada
tanto como Isabel segunda entonces la
población sí tiene un termómetro y ese
termómetro lo mantuvo por el alto debido
al excelente desempeño de la reina que
en paz descanse que dio todo por su país
antes que por su familia entonces ahora
tenemos un rey que no llega de la mejor
manera la serie de Es realmente una daga
una daga que le cae al rey porque las
nuevas generaciones están enterando de
Tal vez cosas que nosotros hemos leído
en la prensa o que hemos visto en los
periódicos o en las revistas o los
tienen O sea la gente menor de treinta
años se está enterando que el rey no
tenía una conducta buena respecto de su
cónyuge respecto de sexual de su vida
sentimental y eso es uno y después el
ejemplo del hermano los problemas de los
hijos Obviamente que eso se iba a
afectar en algún momento la credibilidad
de la monarquía y puede bajar el nivel y
ellos están conscientes de eso
dependiendo todos los líos familiares a
Camila la de llegó a conocer no no no
Cuál va a ser su rol en cualquier caso
como reina consorte
eso vamos a ver tampoco tiene mucho que
hacer pero es decir o se va de de como
paseando la muñeca ahí de la no con uno
o algo entonces abriendo cerrando
eventos este tipo de cosas No creo que
va a opinar no pero el problema de
Camila y y es Interesante como es de una
enorme paciencia y seguramente con la
lealtad de Carlos
Ha logrado sobrevivir el sentido
profundo entre muchos ingleses muchos
británicos que ella era de una forma u
otra la asesina de la princesa Diana
no
pero pero es decir Entonces como era
tanque querida Diana más toda la
inflación mediática que que hacía mucho
no también el personaje de Diana se
idealizó O sea sí es un espectáculo
enorme entonces ahí estaba la la bruja
la la Camila es la mala Entonces ha
logrado mucho en ese sentido Ya bueno
llaman 25 años que se ha calmado la sí
no me parece que eso también habla de un
cambio en los tiempos de cómo hoy se ven
los vínculos las relaciones y me parece
que como bien decía el otro invitado
como que ha ayudado muchísimo que se
conozcan algunas cosas a través de las
series y de historias Me parece que
también es verdad que ahora hay otros
escándalos que tienen que ver con las
relaciones con los hijos lo de Mega
Merkel Bueno si va a estar bueno que no
va a estar presente la ceremonia
entonces me parece que ya finalmente
Camila al final es una heroína que ha
transitado todo esto ha soportado todo
digamos todo ocupar el lugar de Villana
incluso lo que ha contado él Que bueno
que me parece que mañana en un punto se
consagra una historia que
viene de tantos años no y siempre fue
algo de la corona que estuvo ahí sí
por ejemplo el príncipe de galas que era
el hijo de la reina Victoria era un
escándaloso espantoso increíble tenía
una cantidad enorme de hijos pasaba
mucho tiempo aquí en París y en Francia
en general cuando yo llegué a Francia me
dijeron todavía hay gente hay hay se
encuentra gente parecido al de Eduard
siete después
pero no se hablaban de ustedes o se
hablaba entre los círculos no salía todo
en la prensa todo el tiempo hoy por
ejemplo cada vez que la la hace alguna
cosa ahí sacude todo el el la monarquía
una cosa Absurda ella es de una cierta
forma es el
es la punta de flecha del republicanismo
ella puede acabar con todo estuvo
intención yo creo además Bueno luego
está la agenda política de Carlos que ha
prometido revisar a fondo el pasado
colonial inglés el tema de la esclavitud
luego está sus compromisos ecológicos
que desde luego Siempre han sido
patentes al Cesar lo que es del César no
sé si sus reinados era bueno para dar un
empujón a la lucha por el planeta por
parte de los ecologistas o en cualquier
caso si está adaptando esta agenda
política a la sensibilidades actuales
para que sobreviva la monarquía Elda Yo
creo por un lado siempre estuvo muy
comprometido como activista con estas
cuestiones lo ha hecho público pero es
verdad que hoy también tiene que volver
a enamorar a un sector que ya no está
que no sigue tanto como decíamos antes a
la monarquía y que sí tiene muchos
compromisos ecológicos Me parece que su
participación por ejemplo en el Foro de
davos eso es todo un hito para un rey
que participe que hable y que comente y
que proponga no también cómo se puede
llegar a mejorar y cómo se tienen
comprometer los inversores con las
empresas con los proyectos que que
luchen contra el cambio climático parece
que en ese aspecto obviamente él tiene
un compromiso muy grande y que hay una
estrategia de también acercar a esos
Pues también invitó a greta no estuvo
con ella digo me parece que son gestos
que son muy importantes obviamente otros
los critican porque dice por un lado es
un doble discurso Porque sigo usando el
avión privado y la y la y los aviones
que bueno la huella de carbono que es
como una estrategia pero yo creo que a
lo la historia del demostrado un
compromiso con con ese tema y bueno y lo
pone en la mesa
de todo el mundo en Inglaterra se le
tomaba el pelo siempre porque decía que
era un hombre es nuestro príncipe abraza
los árboles era eso
entonces y y y que las plantas le hablan
Entonces entonces entonces nuestro
príncipe tampoco chiflado pero la verdad
es que sus puntos están 20 30 años antes
de de lo que sea hoy hoy se se habla
Pues le voy a preguntar eso a nuestra
historia de Arnaldo Mirando al futuro al
reinado de Carlos tantas veces llamado
de transición o minimizado cómo va a
intentar Carlos llevar a la contraria a
esa minimización e intentar que su
reinado sea fructífero en qué patas
puede basarse él ya ahora está en una
posición diferente y ya no puede opinar
él ya no puede entrar a tallar como
entraba en cosas que podían causar
si discu como el tema de la arquitectura
en Londres o el tema de opiniones serias
No ahora es el soberano él tiene que
estar por encima de todos así como
Isabel segunda sobrevivió y sacó a
Inglaterra de la mejor manera de la
crisis del canal de suez que pudo
haberla llevado una guerra porque todo
el mundo quería enviar al ejército a
ocupar Egipto de nuevo hubiera sido un
retroceso al colonialismo y ella tomó la
decisión de no intervenir es uno de los
mejores ejemplos de un golpe ácido
veremos qué pasa con la Guerra de
Ucrania veremos qué pasa con las
relaciones exteriores de su país pero él
tiene que dar un punto de inflexión de
consejo y de escuchar sus primeros
ministros me queda muy poco tiempo pero
les quiero preguntar creen que la
fascinación es el elemento fundamental
que permite perpetuarse a la monarquía
en el caso británico muy cortito Yo creo
que es el show el show pero un elemento
de fascinación en gran parte que los
productos audiovisuales mucho
algunas veces estaba en Londres cuando
se murió la reina el el el la próxima
mañana yo fui ella se murió en Escocia
pero yo fui a baking en Palace nomás
para ver la reacción ya la gente estaba
Llegando llegando y dejando flores y
todo y era una especie de
de show ese show colectivo cuenta mucho
me quedo sin tiempo para más una frase
no coincido y creo que igual en algún
lado la tradición también para los
británicos sigue existiendo y es
importante
en este caso
Muchísimas gracias a los tres ha sido un
placer estar con ustedes y a todos
ustedes hasta la próxima semana quien en
Primera Plana gracias
[Música]